today i'm going to be speaking with mike
rinder who's a former senior executive
of the church of scientology as well as
the sea
organization uh mike it's so great to
have you on today
thanks david it's lovely to be here so
i've interviewed both
first and second generation scientology
members i know that often the dynamics
for one's relationship to scientology
are different depending on whether your
parents
were were uh um already part of it when
you were born or not talk to us a little
bit about your path in
okay i'm a second generation
scientologist
my parents got involved in scientology
in australia uh when hubbard went there
to do some lectures
in 1959 and so
from a very young age i was raised
in a scientology family and then
once i finished high school i joined
what's called the sea organization
which is the like the elite
inner core of scientology people that
devote their entire lives to
uh supposedly achieving the aims of the
religion
they sign a billion year contract
yep billion uh because scientologists
believe that you
live many different lifetimes and your
spirit transcends
bodies and so you commit yourself
basically to
an eternity of service of scientology
and i did that from the age of uh
18 until i left when i was
53. so there there's already
five branching paths we we could go down
here let's
let's address a few maybe of the the
sort of
uh nuts and bolts you say when you
finished high school
is scientology big on people
that are part of the sea org not going
to college
absolutely i mean everything in
scientology is based on what
hubbard's view of things are and hubbard
had a very
negative opinion of uh
educational systems and educational
institutions
partly because he dropped out of college
but also he figured that he had
uh come up with a tech a quote
technology of study
that made everything else sort of
irrelevant and because
he believed that scientology addresses
everything there is to know about life
and
the world that it was far more important
for children to be educated in
scientology
than educated in
meaning non-scientology stuff
got it and then in terms of the sea org
i know that
other sea org former sea org folks i've
spoken to
say they got no salary they basically
got
housing and then that was part of the
way that
the church would exert control over them
was that your situation
yeah absolutely david that's every
everybody who is in the sea organization
is becomes basically an indentured
servant
right the to the organization of
scientology
in other words you live you
eat your health care whatever it may be
is provided by scientology
you don't earn uh money
per se you get what's called a stipend
which can range from
nothing to fifty dollars a week
maybe if you're lucky and you
so you have no resources
available you most ceo members do not
own
a vehicle they don't own a house
they don't have any sort of worldly
means
many of them joined the sea organization
even younger than i did they don't even
have a high school diploma
they don't have any anything
that allows them or would allow them
to walk out into the real world and
carry on a normal life so the fear
within the sea organization and
and it's something that is cultivated
is that stepping outside of the sea
organization
is going to be a tantamount to
committing suicide
you know there there's this old uh joke
not
so much a joke but a statement that goes
around in the in the sea org
is if you leave the sea org all you'll
do
is end up living under a bridge or
flipping burgers at mcdonald's
that you don't have any any other
avenue to pursue in life other than what
we are offering you
so at some point you start to work your
way
up and you start to actually
uh you you eventually become chief
spokesperson and representative of
scientology to the media
at that point or maybe to put it a
different way
at what point did you start to have
doubts
about your everything that you were
doing and what you had been told
i started to have doubts um
probably about five years before i left
and i left in 2007
so in the early 2000s but you have to
understand david that having
doubts is there is this enormous
push and pull of what you've been taught
in scientology and there is a very
fundamental principle that hubbard
uses to you know hang on to people
which is that your
condition whatever whatever condition
you find yourself
in is your own you've caused that
that you've caused if it's a bad state
of affairs you've caused it by doing bad
things and so when
you and it even is down to the level of
if you're contemplating leaving this
organization
it means that you've done bad things to
this organization
so you get this push and pull oh my god
something's wrong here oh my scientology
teaching
tells me that that's because i've done
something bad
and i need to look inside within myself
and figure out what that is
so and there are a lot of other factors
that go into it like
i had two children and a wife if i
decide i wish to leave
then that becomes a problem because
if i tell my wife she's probably going
to report me
and then i'll be stopped if i
don't tell her i'm going to lose my
wife and children so there's a
and and that's just the sort of most
surface factors so talk a little bit
about the concept i've heard before
about
i will be prevented from leaving and
what i want to understand is
as a general thing someone calls the
police and says they're being held
against their will
for example and police show up and and
you know you don't even really need a
warrant in that situation
you're able to verify someone's
well-being
did you even have access to a phone
could you even call police if you are
being held against your will well this
this depends on where you're at where i
was
at golden era productions the
international headquarters of
scientology in riverside county you
don't
have commonly access to a phone and the
phones that are there
in order to be able to make any call you
have to go via reception
i see but beneath that david is
there is another very well inculcated
idea in scientology that going to the
police
or law enforcement is a big no-no
this is just not done nobody
goes to call the police or
do something that is
outside of the world of scientology to
solve a problem within scientology
now obviously if you're if you're
at the point where you're ready to jump
the fence
and run down the the highway in the
middle of nowhere and hope
that someone's going to pick you up then
you're not in that mindset but it takes
a lot of a lot
of uh thinking outside the bubble
that you exist in to get to that point
right and by very definition because
you're
in a bubble of agreed upon
thoughts and ideas and everybody else
agrees with you
and what's right and what's wrong is all
agreed upon
it's very difficult to think outside
that bubble
so that's it that's why larry wright so
cleverly
called his book going clear scientology
and the prison of belief
because though there are security guards
there's
lights there's motion sensors on the
fences
there's cameras everywhere etc etc
the real prison of scientology and
particularly seoul members
is here right and
did your some of the former scientology
people i've spoken to
started to take issue with the practices
as an organization but almost continued
having
the doctrine beliefs even after they
left
were your doubts with one the other or
both
with primarily one the the organization
and david miscavige interesting so your
initial problem was not
you didn't believe the that aliens
previously were here or z
you weren't doubting that you were
doubting the organization correct
it takes and i you know i obviously have
spoken to a lot of former scientologists
and a lot of former sea og members
it's sort of like a stage of
uh peeling the onion of
unburdening yourself of ideas
that have been sort of
built into your dna almost
particularly if you're raised that way
and
the easiest ones are the ones that have
a very physical manifestation
like being beaten up by david miscavige
is something that's a very you know
tangible here and now thing
the ideas of that dianetics and
hubbard's book dianetics
is a load of bunk takes a lot longer
to get sort of shed
because it's it's not so it's not so
tangible
that makes a lot of sense and i i mean
when when you it it seems as though
it takes in a sense more although
in a physical sense the decision
to leave or try to leave uh seems like
the piece that's most difficult it seems
that maybe the beliefs that have been
ingrained in you your entire life are
really the most difficult although in a
different way
yeah you're you're absolutely right
david
and i don't think that there is anybody
that you will ever talk to who is a
former scientologist that will tell you
anything different than that
you were a shared
talk about what it means to be in the
hole and your experience in the hole for
two years
it's um well it's really a prison
it was a a prison that was created
at the international headquarters by
david miscavige in
a double-wide trail a building that was
constructed out of two double wide
trailers
and the doors were bad and the windows
were screwed shut
and there was a security guard at the
only
access point to the building and
we were put in there to um
figure out why we were suppressive
persons
and a suppressive person in scientology
means
someone who is intent upon destroying
mankind
right and miscavitch david miscavige the
the ecclesiastical leader of the
scientology religion as he likes to call
himself
was um
always seeking to
be the person who was
the doc the big dog the dominant
personality
in the environment and kept anybody who
was a potential threat to his control of
the organization
constantly in a state of am i in trouble
am i not in trouble am i going to be
you know sent to to shovel in louisiana
am i am i in good graces today
and the whole was sort of the final
manifestation of this where he basically
took
everybody who was at the senior echelon
of scientology and put them in this
prison and said
when you guys figure out why you're
so bad maybe you can get out
right and that devolved in this
you know going clear gives a pretty good
depiction of some of what happened the
the alex gibney
movie the hbo movie but the
the the truth of the matter is it
devolved
into a sort of a lord of the flies world
of people striving to
demonstrate to david miscavige
that they were more on his team than
anybody else
by attacking the other people
and saying you know you're a bad person
or beating them up or
yelling at them or you know famously in
the case of debbie cook who was put
there and testified on the stand that
she was put in a garbage can
with a sign around her neck and people
poured water over her
until she was shivering in and
being physically and and verbally abused
this happened as the sort of um
routine that ended up being in the hole
and it was pretty pretty uh
both bizarre and
horrifying and shocking and
uh a little unbelievable to think that
that
could be happening in today's
united states of america yeah well i
think that's that's the question a lot
of people in the audience have which is
how is how is it happening we're going
to continue our conversation and the
full conversation will be posted on our
youtube channel
we're going to go to a break on the
podcast tv and radio show
we've been speaking of course with mike
rinder a former senior executive of the
church of scientology and the sea org
the full conversation will be on our
youtube channel
mike when it comes to medical treatment
we've many of us have seen
the tom cruise video about when it comes
to psychiatry and mental health and
curing addiction nobody can do with
scientology you know etc
from in the day to day if you have a
sinus infection
does scientology just say you take an
antibiotic i mean
it generally speaking how what's the
perspective on
traditional standard medical treatment
okay
this is this is a question that has uh
an answer that isn't black and white
generally scientologists do not
uh have a great deal of faith
in the medical profession okay um
absolutely black and white they have
absolutely
no faith in any psychiatric
psychological mental health field that
is absolutely taboo medical doctors
are seen as a sort of a necessary
evil like if you break your leg you need
to have a doctor to set the bones
if you have a sinus infection
like you said if it can't be cured with
scientology
touch assists which is a thing that
hubbard invented on
uh oh mike we just lost you there
oh boy in scientology then you probably
will be sent to a doctor
and if if
mike we got your audio back for a second
but we totally lost your video
okay now you're back now you're back
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh i'm back
you're back
okay where did you get today we really
got most of it that when it comes to you
know
ideally when maybe with the touch points
something could be solved but
if not there would be a reluctant
acceptance of medical treatment
yeah hubbard had a very dim view of the
medical profession because
they did not accept dynamics right and
he believed that dianetics was the cure
for all of man's ills
including physical ills i mean dianetics
the book
still contains all these passages that
say this cures bursitis and arthritis
and
heart disease and blah blah blah blah
blah
pretty radical claims of medical
results that don't exist but
the other concept in scientology is that
illness only happens and
you are predisposed to being becoming
ill
if you are connected to one of these
suppressive people
yeah and that's not that different from
ideas from other religions that
illness is a result of either not
praying enough or the right way or of
some kind of sin
absolutely i mean there are a lot of
things in scientology that are not a
whole lot different than
other religions what is different about
scientology
is the
one of the things about scientology that
sets it apart
is that hubbard wrote down everything he
wrote
everything and made it available to
people within scientology and that
includes all
of his um
directives to destroy people
use private investigators uh
disassociate
and disconnect families to uh eradicate
enemies to destroy psychiatry all of
this stuff is written down it's all
like in black and white writing by
hubbard and this is what scientologists
practice and and believe and
you know it's it's certainly okay to
believe anything you want you can
believe in space aliens you can believe
the earth is flat you can believe that
there was a virgin birth
all of these things there's plenty of
radical beliefs that exist in all sorts
of mainstream
religious thought what you can't do
is do things that hurt and harm people
right and do things that are in
violation of the law
and that's what you know
those of us that call ourselves
whistleblowers about scientology are
seeking to end
we're not trying to end scientology as a
thought process or a belief system
we're trying to end the abuses the
families being broken up people being
bankrupted uh
you know people being harassed that
stuff
that's that's where the the crux of the
problem with scientology is
in summary when you left did the wife
and kids go with you
and what degree of harassment have you
experienced since leaving
okay no my wife and kids did not go with
me
um i wrote to them as soon as i
had a spot to settle in and asked if
they would
come and my wife at the time wrote back
a very uh terse letter saying
i'm filing the divorce papers um
as for harassment uh pretty much the
whole
gamut i've had spy sitting on me and gps
devices put on my cars and cameras set
up outside
my homes my garbage taken and gone
through
yeah the going through for some reason
scientology investigators seem to love
riffling through garbage everybody i've
spoken to mentions that
well it's it's sort of a it's like a
technique
that that private investigators use uh
because and scientology used because
people tend to be uh pretty careless
about their garbage and there's all
sorts of things that you might find in
there for
it's not like you're gonna find your you
know
the the admission that oh
i stole ten thousand dollars from
scientology but
maybe a pill bottle that shows what
prescription you're taking
right or maybe you know there's all
sorts of
information to be gleaned from that but
today
i think that scientology's biggest
uh means of seeking to harass
people who are speaking out about it is
on the internet
i mean they're a massive they have a
massive number of websites and
urls and they're on twitter and they're
on facebook and they're all over the
place
spreading ridiculous lies about
everybody i mean and and it's funny to
look at them david because
you see almost every person is got the
same
uh modifiers and adjectives used to
describe them
they're bitter they're defrocked they're
got an axe to grind they're a thief
they're
a liar they're this they're that and
it i think that one thing that the
aftermath
accomplished when we kept
showing or reading the letters that
scientology would send about all the
people that we're talking about
was to discredit the
the barrage that scientology
puts forth about anybody who says
anything i mean you're probably going to
get
something about you now you know i've
done a lot of these and i haven't so far
that i've seen but yeah i i've
considered it could happen
well yeah you haven't done me
well listen there was there was one
other thing i wanted to ask about to get
your insight into this about a decade
ago my mom
acts i mean she she deliberately hired a
handyman
that she did not know was a
scientologist until after she hired him
and when she was on vacation she asked
me to just check in on how the work was
going and the guy
let slip uh hey have you ever heard of l
ron hubbard and i could tell that this
was sort of an initial
entreaty to kind of gauge my reaction
and i said yeah the science fiction guy
who made up scientology right
and he immediately told me oh that's
what suppressive people say
really kind of jumping right in right
but here's the detail i'm curious
about the next day when i went to check
on the work
he had left an outgoing letter in my
mom's mailbox
to the church of scientology in
philadelphia where his son worked
he could have sent this from anywhere he
could have sent it from his house he
could have dropped it off at the post
office
is there i mean maybe you're speculating
but is there some
signal that he was maybe trying to send
to me
or to the postal service about my mom in
some way
what's the point of sending this letter
from my mom's house
i think it was just lazy
[Laughter]
there's nothing so special about that
okay he also was a rush limbaugh fan i
don't know if politically
scientology tends to be conservative in
that way
oh yes okay generally i would say that
scientology
is conservative for and and this is
really for two reasons david one
because if there is something related to
psychiatry
that is a live or die
one decision issue for
all scientologists so if democrats are
proposing
uh health care for all which includes
mental health
i see no way i see i see no way
and the second thing is that hubbard
generally
was very anti-government you know the
government
of the united states and britain and
australia and south africa and
i mean governments everywhere france
everywhere always were after him
so he always announced very
loudly to his followers that you know
governments are composed of bad
people trying to do bad things to
destroy
mankind and enslave people and blah blah
blah
and so the idea of
big government is anathema generally to
scientologists
that makes that makes a lot of sense
when thought of uh when thought of that
way
we've been speaking with mike rinder
former senior executive
of the church of scientology and the sea
org
mike it's been such a pleasure having
you on thanks for telling us your story
you're very welcome david it's been a
pleasure being with you